BELIEFS -- PROVIDING FOR 4,000
PEOPLE.
WORKS FOR HORRIBLE NEWS, JOINS
US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS HARD TO BELIEVE, THIS
STORY.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER AMISH
FARMERS.
WHO ARE "THEY?"
>> THE U.S. NATIONAL SERVICE --
RECENTLY RATED THIS ORGANIC AND
HOLISTIC FARM, AND AS YOU SAID,
CHARGED THEM WITH $300,000 IN
FINES.
YOU HAVE TO BE ARMED FEDERAL --
STOPPING FOOD PRODUCTIONS
BECAUSE OF MEAT, AND YOU HAVE
HIM SAYING "I'M GOING TO KEEP
FARMING."
SO YOU HAVE THIS BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE GIANT U.S.
GOVERNMENT CAN AND THESE TINY
FARMS.
>> SO THEY WENT AFTER GYMS,
ORGANIC FARMERS, AND CHURCHES?
SO, ANYTHING CLOSE TO EDIFYING
THAT MAKES YOU STRONGER,
HEALTHIER, AND ANYTHING -- DID
YOU SEE THIS?
>> ANOTHER THING THE COMMUNITY
SAYS THAT THEY ARE COMING AFTER
THEM TO SET AN EXAMPLE, COMING
AFTER AN INDIVIDUAL
DOMINIC INDEPENDENT, SUCCESSFUL
FARMER, WHO PROVIDES TO HIS
PEOPLE.
BY TAKING UP THE GOVERNMENT,
HE'S TAKING POWER AND LEVERAGE
AWAY FROM THE GOVERNMENT, AND
PUTTING IT IN THE HANDS OF THE
COMMUNITY, THE FARMERS.
DOESN'T USE ANY GASOLINE OR
FERTILIZERS.
IT'S BECOME VERY EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S POLICIES IN
THE UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
ELIMINATED ANY RISK -- FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL POLITICS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> LOOKING FOR CHEMICALS AND
MILK TO TURN KIDS TRANS.
AND ANYONE DECLINED TO RAISE AN
AMISH ORGANIC FARM?
>> ALL I KNOW IS THAT FEDERAL
AGENTS DID NOT DECLINED TO GO
AND DID GO ALONG WITH IT.
TO MAKE SURE HE DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE PRODUCE ANY MORE MEAT.
>> I PREFER LAW ENFORCEMENT
BROADLY SPEAKING, BUT THERE IS
SUCH A THING AS CONSCIENCE.
WHEN THEY TELL YOU TO CREATE AN
ORGANIC, AMISH FARM, THAT'S WHEN
YOU BOW